[Música]
miles de inmigrantes alcanzaron ceuta
una pequeña ciudad española en la costa
mediterránea de marruecos algunos
llegaron nadando alrededor de las vallas
fronterizas y muchos de ellos usaron
inflables o botes de goma otros
caminaron durante la marea baja para
muchos el viaje va de los riesgos los
jóvenes quieren irse no hay trabajo no
tengo miedo si nos quedamos aquí si
tendría miedo debo irme para salvarme
mucho muere o cruzo cuando no tienes
nada y debes pagar la renta y cuidar de
tus hijos y tus padres no hay lugar para
el miedo la mayoría son hombres jóvenes
aunque también hay mujeres y niños
quienes fueron trasladados a un centro
de recepción migratoria sólo el lunes se
llegaron unas 5000 personas incluidos
mil menores un récord de arribos en un
solo día
junto con melilla otra ciudad española
en el norte de áfrica ceuta es el único
territorio de la unión europea con
frontera terrestre con áfrica esto atrae
a migrantes africanos que buscan llegar
a europa desde las playas ubicadas unos
pocos kilómetros al sur en marruecos se
trata de un viaje muy riesgoso que será
en vano para la mayoría madrid y rabat
acordaron recientemente que españa
regresaría a ciudadanos marroquíes a su
país de origen sobre los menores no
acompañados tienen permitido quedarse el
ministerio del interior español anunció
un refuerzo de las fuerzas de seguridad
en la zona de escalada en las llegadas
ocurre en medio de las tensiones
diplomáticas entre los dos países por la
situación en el sáhara occidental'